[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Building the
cloud for everyone
takes everyone to
create and embrace
a culture that is inclusive
and representative
of our communities.
Here at Next '19 in San
Francisco, diversity, equality,
and inclusion is
part of our DNA.
Recently, "Forbes Magazine"
recognized our commitment,
naming Next as one of
the top three conferences
for women to thrive.
Let's check in with Joanna for
more on the Inclusion Lounge,
and the #IAmRemarkable workshops
happening here at Next.
JOANNA SMITH: Thanks
so much, Stephanie.
I'm so excited to be here
at our Inclusion Lounge
because diversity is
something that I obviously
care a lot about.
But more important
than just being diverse
is making sure that we
have multiple perspectives
at the table so that we can
build really interesting
solutions to fun problems.
So now we're talking to Taylor,
who drives diversity, equity,
and inclusion at Next.
Hi.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Hi, Joanna.
JOANNA SMITH: This
lounge is great.
You want to tell me
some fun facts about it?
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Welcome
to the Inclusion Lounge.
And the purpose of
Inclusion Lounge
is to make sure that at Next
we're always providing content
and experiences to support
underrepresented groups
and allies, to be able
to come together, share
learnings, collaborate,
and build community.
So, yeah.
It's a safe space,
and at anytime people
could drop by, connect
with like-minded others,
get confidence coaching,
and also get headshots.
And then in the
interim, we also have
sessions like I Am
Remarkable, which is going
on right around our shoulder.
JOANNA SMITH: I
love that session.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Yeah,
and this session
is happening a
couple times at Next.
And it takes us
through an exercise
of empowerment and learning
how to promote ourselves
in all the positive ways.
JOANNA SMITH: What
do you think really
makes the Inclusion
Lounge stand out,
and why should people
think about coming here
during their day?
TAYLOR NGUYEN:
Yeah, you know what?
It's not even about
thinking about it.
It's just knowing
that it's available
because so much about
inclusion is you have
to be ready to be in the space.
JOANNA SMITH: Yes.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: And when
you're ready to receive
and you're ready to learn from
others, and become an ally
or become an advocate, that's
the time to actually visit.
And it shouldn't be
an intimidating space.
It should be a space
where you could feel
like you could be welcomed.
You can meet like-minded people,
and you can actually learn
and listen from one another.
Our attendees are
always sharing with us
that whether they're an
introvert or an extrovert,
they need a place to
unwind and step away
from the commotion of Next and
all the wonderful experiences
that are available here.
And then they're
really able to then go
from a collaborative
mindset, rather
than an overwhelmed mindset.
JOANNA SMITH: Thank you again
for building this space.
I really admire it.
TAYLOR NGUYEN: Thanks for
coming to talk to us about it.
And always feel that
you could drop by
and Inclusion Lounge
because we all know it's
really important at Next to
build a cloud for everyone.
Thanks everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]